hey guys
welcome to yet another interesting and
informative video by simply learn in
this video we will understand the data
type cnc programming before we get
started make sure that you subscribe to
our simply loan channel and hit the bell
icon to never miss an update from us
without further ado let's get started
with the agenda for today's session
first
we will start by understanding what data
types in c are
next is the classification of data types
after that the basic data types and the
modifiers
and finally the derived and user-defined
data types in c
so i hope i have made myself clear with
the agenda and we are good to get
started
now let's begin with what are data types
in c
data types are used to notify the type
of value assigned to a variable
four basic data types in c are int float
care and double and the general syntax
of data type is data type variable list
and semicolon at the end
great now that we know what are data
types in c
now let us understand the classification
of data types
three data types are classified into
three types
first up we have basic data types
which are int care float and double
then we have derived data types in which
we have arrays and pointers
and finally user defined data types
which are inum structure and union
first let us understand four basic data
types in c
variables of type in hold integer values
ranging from negative three to seven six
eight to positive three to seven six
seven and it occupies two bytes of
memory size in this example ea b and sum
are the variables of type in that hold
integer values
next
the variables of type care hold a single
ascii character that contains numbers
from 1 to 9 small and capital letters e
to z and some special characters
enclosed within two single quotes
and occupies one byte of memory space
it ranges from negative 128 to positive
127.
the flow data type variables occupy 4
bytes of memory space that holds the
value with decimal points that is up to
6 decimal places for example pi and h
are the variables of type float they
range from 3.4 into 10 to the power of
negative 38 to positive 38.
the variables of type double hold values
with decimal points and occupy 8 bytes
of memory space in this example a is the
variable of type double ranging from 1.7
into 10 to the power of negative 308 to
positive 308.
now let's have a look at the modifiers
in c
modifiers are also known as qualifiers
are used to modify the basic data types
in c
and the qualifiers are signed unsigned
short and long
signed modifiers are used to hold both
negative and positive numbers at the
same time unsigned is used to store only
negative numbers
so it's necessary to prefix the
qualifier before the data types
and short requires memory space half the
size of the basic data type a long
modifier is used to hold large numbers
and it doubles the size of the data type
the general syntax of handling modifier
is modifier basic data type variable
list and semicolon so in this particular
example unsigned is a modifier ind is a
basic data type and a is a variable
we cannot apply qualifiers to the flow
data type but we can increase the size
of the double data type by using a long
qualifier also we cannot apply
qualifiers long and short on the cad
data type
not just this there are also a wide
variety of data types available in c
programming language that comes in handy
when you level up to the next stage with
respect to your data
let's look at the table that displays
you the next range of data types and
their format specifiers you might want
to take a screenshot for future
reference
okay let's get started with care
for the data types cad signed cad and
unsigned cad the size is one byte and
its format specifier is percentage c
next int the size is two bytes and its
format specifier is percentage d
unsign it the size is two bytes and its
format specifier is percentage u
next is long int
the size is 4 bytes and its format
specifier is percentage reality
unsigned long int the size is 4 bytes
and its format specifier is percentage
elu
next data type is float
the size is 4 bytes and its format
specifier is percentage f
double the size is 8 bytes and its
format specifier is percentage glf
next we have long double the size is 10
bytes and its format specifier is
percentage capital lf
now let's have a look at derived data
types as discussed earlier array and
pointers fall under derived data types
the array is a collection of elements of
the same data type and that can be of
int float care and double data types
as you all can see in this example the
array stores six elements of the same
type int
next
a pointer is a variable that holds the
address of another variable declined
under any basic data type
in this example the pointer variable
holds the address of normal variables in
which the value 50 is stored
so i think you got a good understanding
of derived data types
okay so let us now understand
user-defined data types in c
inum is an enumeration data type that
holds constant integer values defined by
the user the syntax of nm data type is
inum inom name and list of constant in
this particular example inm is a keyword
furniture as in a name and j table book
rack would be constants
next
this structure is a collection of
elements having same or different data
types
as you can see in this example the
elements declared as struct are of
different data types a variable a is of
type int and b is of type float
and finally
we have a union data type that holds the
different data type elements in the same
memory location
in the following example the union is a
keyword followed by that we have a union
name and then the variable list
so with this we have come to the end of
this session on the data types in c
programming i hope this session was
informative and interesting until next
time thank you stay safe and keep
learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here
you